[Music]
between Ant-Man getting a movie trilogy
morbius The Living vampire becoming an
ironic internet sensation and Moon
Knight fumbling the ball we as audiences
have become a little desensitized to big
budget summer blockbuster movies about
relatively obscure Marvel characters
but there was a time when something like
this was so much more surprising and
delightful during the mid-2000s
superhero movies were finally finding
their footing with the use of
photorealistic VFX finally being able to
render these characters in a believable
way
usually these huge budgets big name
actors and high quality special effects
were saved for characters your grandmas
probably heard of like X-men Spider-Man
Superman Batman Fantastic Four The Hulk
and characters that were at least kind
of recognizable like Daredevil Iron Man
or The Punisher blade is a weird happy
accident but one character in particular
always felt like a strange one to get a
movie in the same year as dancing Man 3
and the rise of Galactus cloud
thank you
now word from our sponsor in 2020 there
were over 5 million car crashes that's
more than 15 000 a day and 600 an hour
just back in December my own dad slid
off an icy Road and broke his hip in
four places and the thought of getting
legal help was so daunting for him
those in an accident can be entitled to
more than you think when something like
that happens it's always good to have
someone in your corner looking out for
your best interest someone like the fine
folks at Morgan and Morgan if you've
been in an accident there are certain
things you need to do make sure you're
okay make sure you get a police report
make sure you contact your insurance so
if you're injured and don't know where
to start with Morgan and Morgan it's so
easy Morgan and Morgan have modernized
injury law by making the process as easy
and streamlined as possible so you can
submit a claim in eight clicks or less
no need for you to visit law offices and
sit through timely consultations you can
submit a claim and have a lawyer review
your case and get started on helping you
right away you can submit your case
details sign contracts upload documents
and medical records all from your cell
phone and you can even text your
attorney and legal team throughout the
duration of your case with Morgan and
Morgan you can submit a claim without
ever having to leave the couch if you're
ever injured in an accident you can
check out Morgan and Morgan for more
information go to forthepeople.com or
pound law
that's pound 529 from your cell phone
now back to the video
a character I was convinced only
hardcore comic fans knew about or like
bikers that had tattoos of him maybe
people who grew up with his few minor
appearances in 90s superhero cartoons I
knew about him because my dad told me
about the character and I had a few
Ghost Rider action figures so seeing him
on the big screen when I was like seven
years old was the coolest [__] ever and
this movie came out as early as it
possibly could have in the lineage of
comic book films you really couldn't do
this character in live action before the
Advent of CGI motion tracking imagine
this movie in the 80s he'd be like a guy
in a mask with his head on fire and it
just wouldn't evoke the same visceral
feeling of seeing this character design
and going
whoa that's awesome that all being said
these movies are sort of strange
anomalies Looking Back Now and almost
feel like two separate unrelated
attempts to adapt the same character
that incidentally shared a leading man
in Nick Cage as the star
hi
there's a lot of bizarrely different
creative decisions between the two of
these that I feel are worth examining if
only because they were such experimental
movies in this genre that can now feel a
little bit formulaic let's dive into
what made the two Ghost Rider movies so
strange and yet so interesting and try
to figure out why a potential big
contender in the world of comic book
movies didn't quite make it to a full
Trilogy it wouldn't be the 2000s without
some grit and some Edge so I've turned
to the guy that most likely got our
Marvel anime video flagged as too adult
by talking about boobs for three solid
minutes the Danny catch to my Johnny
Blaze the zarathos in my motorcycle my
boy the one and only muzzy
hey what can I say you put a skull guy
in all black leather without it
irritating my Nethers and put some
spikes in a chain on them I'm gonna say
that's pretty cool I can't remember if
this first movie is what introduced me
to the character or not but he is one
that's always caught my interest with
his ongoing Legacy and cool crossovers
like the original midnight Sons I still
haven't gotten into most of his solo
outing stuff Beyond initial appearances
and stuff to catch up on books I was
more interested in so it's weird that
this movie has stayed with me for so
long probably because I got it on
bootleg look at this hoe
Ghost Rider is the story of a motorcycle
stunt man who made a deal with a
high-ranking demon that's not actually
the devil but he likes people to think
he's the devil even though that's a
separate character insert joke about
Spider-Man being ruined forever here
Johnny Blaze's father and Mentor comes
down with a case of star-lord's mom
disease and a mysterious stranger offers
him a cure in exchange for his signature
and blood and his Immortal soul
the big sea is cured only for the Big G
to take his life instead that being
gravity then this normal looking dude in
his 20s somehow goes so crazy with grief
and isolation that he grows up to be
Nicholas I name myself after Luke Cage
from Marvel Comics Ten Years Later
what's Spider-Man's Lord and Savior has
his place in Hell threatened by his
[__] son Blackheart Blaze is called
into action to be the coolest goddamn
character design ever and pass righteous
judgment on evildoers considering this
is the same director as the first
Daredevil movie this is a pretty slick
movie it's not stylish in a cringy
overly 2000s way like Daredevil was it's
just got a really nice feeling of energy
and a solid pacing that keeps it
interesting the style is more immersive
than it is obnoxious whereas it was
desperate to fit in the time of the
early era of the genre with the best
soundtrack ever that totally doesn't
collide with its tone character and a
surprising allergy to spandex to rival
the x movies it feels natural to the
scenes being more of a spectacle than a
spy firing to be one out of compensation
it doesn't really trust you as an
audience member though being kind of
relying on flashbacks and reminders but
other than that the presentation Works
in his favor the effects are incredibly
well implemented I love the look of
Ghost Rider's hell powers where he
touches stuff and they become a cooler
heavy metal version the transformation
is only four shots with the same setup
yet they're all ingrained into my skull
it's so cool man handle the sound design
involving the rider stands out from his
Roars to the mechanical sounds on his
bike
suspect is going up that was also
something that was a big contrast to DD
cause God that movie sound design is
poopy butt his voice almost reminds me
of his voice in the 90s animated shows
Richard Grieco oh I just want to do a
Greco thing I'm vibing with it he also
voices me Marvel vs Capcom 3 so that's
cool plus the movie's got a very
well-balanced tone you'd expect Ghost
Rider to Warrant an R rating and darker
tone but this works as a PG-13 it's just
violent enough to get the point across
without being over the top or feeling
totally toothless either
though I do wish they committed to doing
more comic bookie designs with
characters other than Ghost Rider
Blackheart has such a cool look in the
comics and the movie committed to making
Jim just the a pale guy oh but don't
forget sometimes when he gets real mad
and serious his demon face comes out and
then when he absorbs all the souls it's
permanent until he gets bitched at the
end they knew they couldn't live up to
his Marvel vs Capcom 2 art I respect him
for that man now I just want to play
Marvel vs Capcom Mephisto straddles the
line of looking badass and ridiculous
but they didn't attempt that either he's
just some old guy in a black trench coat
he looks like he's going to invite you
to [__] his wife that's 30 years younger
than him for ten thousand dollars while
he's going to a country club meeting in
a different city he doesn't even want to
stay and watch that's
oddly specific sign the contract muzzy
sign it virile young man and Blackhearts
goons are just like dirty dudes with bad
Tunes is wallow cool but rude what the
hell and is abigore a party dude ah okay
I get it now the stupid names were hard
to fit into the flow of the theme I
tried I guess they're fine as just
random boss encounters for Ghost Rider
to quickly kill I do like that they each
have their own gimmick and he has to
fight them in a different way each time
so it shows that he's adaptable then
again Ghost Rider is also just
ridiculously overpowered in general
Johnny's character has a surprising bit
of depth too where he's lived in regret
over his deal with Kit Fisto for so many
years that he's become bizarrely
straight edge to the point of seeming a
little bit childish hi
from the horse's mouth it's Johnny
actively staying away from any potential
of sin entirely now that he's directly
tied to it but because of his dated and
Niche intake of media that betrays him
as an old soul I like to see it as him
taking his time with the things he's
found to enjoy in life now that he knows
it can't catch up to him as fast he sees
the trivialization of his skill in the
motor world is entertainment and just
that mostly doing it probably for the
love of it and for his own personal
Pride more than anyone else's
considering he doesn't really have to
take the risk seriously with this whole
situation he's got this youthful and
innocent air about him despite his age
and history he's surprisingly likable
and Charming is our main character
Nicholas Cage seemed to have a lot of
input on how his character was betrayed
and added a lot of subtle Nuance to him
seeing that he's a big fan of the
character hey I know you're a huge fan
of of course I mean for our audience out
there on a scale of one to ten how huge
well turned because I was always
interested in the monsters when I was
reading the comics I like Ghost Rider
and I like the Hulk like the rider being
able to have a sense of humor while not
just being a doofus and still looking
sick as hell the whole time though the
same can't be said for his elonging
lover waiting to throw up my phone
Roxanne played by Eva Longoria AKA Eva
I'ma put my long
crevices of your pelvis you have yeah
your pretty woman must that's an
entirely different actress what the hell
are you talking about scrawny you're
thinking of Eva Longoria of Desperate
Housewives that's this Eva Mendes of Too
Fast Too Furious Fame
I said forget about it she is a
compelling love interest Beyond just
well being Eva Mendes yeah I get it like
she's got the same thing as a lot of
superhero girlfriends around this time
which is just being sad because she got
stood up or or getting kidnapped by the
main villain they could have given Eva
Longoria no Eva Mendes now you got me
doing it [__] sucks Bud they could have
given her more to do in the script but
the movie was already getting long
anyway she's an established reporter and
she shot a gun twice I remember liking
this movie a lot when it came out in
2007. my cousins and I actually snuck
into another theater to watch a second
showing that same day then I sort of
stopped dwelling on it for a long time
and I fully expected to come back to it
and think it's really stupid like a lot
of stuff from my childhood
but this is really competently
structured and executed in terms of
adapting Ghostwriter I'm infamous for
not being huge on Nostalgia which caused
me to Clash with the comments on a lot
of reviews I'm a big proponent of just
because you liked it when you were seven
doesn't mean it's actually good but
looking at this movie again with the
eyes of an adult
it's all right I feel like it was a
first solid entry and it had so much
potential from where it could go from
here some cool stuff included a little
Bare Bones
[Music]
and by the books but the genre was still
finding its footing overall entertaining
but it seems like the movie didn't wow
anyone enough to really warn a strong
demand for a direct sequel the Ghost
Rider series was shelled for four years
which at the time felt like 10 years
because time moved slower when you're a
toddler or whatever by the time this
sequel is finally made a massive shift
in Focus took place because that was a
crucial four years for this genre of
movies
the raymie Spider-Man trilogy ended the
MCU was finally on the rise The Dark
Knight was a massive success that four
years changed everything and Ghost Rider
needed a sequel to keep up with changing
tides
spirit of Vengeance
didn't quite do that Ghost Rider 2
Spirit of Massachusetts is a very weird
direct sequel it almost feels like a
complete reboot but it retains the
casting of cage which does imply it's a
continuation
the tone and feel and style and look and
everything is completely different
but it does have these odd little
references and callbacks to the first
movie that are subtle okay I got it this
feels like the Old Man Logan legacy
sequel in a long series that's doing a
send-off for the character after a bunch
of other sequels and a long gap between
the previous one except this is the
second one in the series it's like we
missed at least four movies in here to
transition this things in the story make
sense to where Johnny ends up at the
point we see him but it still feels like
such a way away from where the OG left
off like yeah he was a wanted man for a
period in the original and that doesn't
really get followed up on but why is he
isolated in a European abandoned
warehouses if he's Bruce Banner or even
with the state of the rider he seemed
like he embraced it by the end the last
one to the point of it not really being
a thing he needs to control but at the
start of this he's this hesitant Beast
that Johnny wants to hide away you'd
think by virtue of them re-filming the
flashback to his deal with Mephisto it's
a full reboot but I think it's an evil
dead sort of thing where they didn't
have the right rights to the original
movie's footage and it was easier to
just film The recap a different way
instead of paying out the ass to get the
old thing which wouldn't have matched
anyway because they recast Mephisto this
new version of Mephisto looks like he'd
run for president on a staunch anti-gay
stance but secretly have a lover named
Chuck do you have some sort of like
Crusade against the guys playing him in
these movies I mean what's going on
that's like two in a row you can't stand
in the way of their love that's even
like what I think of small callbacks to
the original outside of the deal
flashback like him chugging this picture
he did with the coffee pot in the first
movie which when I was young I thought
it was just Johnny B and Johnny but it's
actually because it's hot
he grabbed it fresh off the coffee maker
and starts gulping it down cause it's
hot and he's got fire flowers you get it
all right I said it's Priceless but when
he's doing tricks with Danny on his bike
he does the same move that he did on the
freeway trying to get Roxanne's
attention
this movie may feel like a drastic
departure from the first one but it's
not without its interesting quirks I
love the bombastic crazy editing style
and the Really intense camera work the
action is a real standout for this one
with a lot of practical stunts crazy set
pieces and really memorable moments
interspersed a lot of it at least for me
comes in the mere presence of the rider
he's a lot of fun in the original being
badass and toying with his enemies in a
goofy way a lot of the time
but here he's way more monstrous instead
of playing with his enemies he's like
prepping for his prey in his first
appearance here intentionally scaring
them being a blur to them at times in a
way that I can see is being obnoxious in
his presentation to some but I feel it
emphasizes him being this demonics the
natural entity aesthetically too he's
got a grimier look that I love here he's
more clean cutting the original with his
Sleek leather and his shiny spikes with
his bike pertaining to flame decals and
molded demonic accessories but here he's
full on charcoal sporting a darker
meaner skull with the Char jacket that
you can see the love that bubbling and
even dripping at times which is in
amazing detail along with this bike
looking like he's come right out of an
industrial oven the sound design stays
consistent too his Roars are lower
pitched and less gargledy with his
Rippling ghastly howl that falls behind
whenever he appears
foreign
[Music]
a parallel we found between these and
the Venom movies of all things is that
in the original installment the title
character's voices are more monstrous
and unique to them but then in his
sequel will emphasize the actor's voice
through set character it's way more
apparent than Venom than it is here
because it's very obviously more
effective here with him having more of
an eerie whisper
does it hurt it looks like it does but
still a weird connection the contrast
between the five of them is very jarring
and I do overall like him in the
original more when it comes to how he's
betrayed but I think each version
enhances their own specific style
feeling right in line with the vision of
both
though I'd say that hesitantly when it
comes to the second it's just a shame
that everything in between the action
scenes sucks
dick hey kids you like Terminator 2 well
here you go
he bounced from the coolest fight scenes
you've ever seen to some of the most
dull lifeless melodramatic [__] with
characters that I couldn't name two
things about whenever his skull isn't on
fire this movie's in full autopilot oh
it does try to break the monotony with
some bizarrely immature humor that it
doesn't really commit hard enough to
like seeing Johnny's naked butt Flaps in
animated form uh a goon talking about is
recurring testicular aches and Ghost
Rider pissing fire LOL poopoo is what we
call that in the industry when so many
long stretches the movie take itself so
seriously these feel really out of place
it's like they couldn't decide between
being goofy schlock or trying to be a
legitimate end of the world Story the
first movie had a much easier time
balancing its tone it's weird when goofy
is these guys as element the first movie
had melodramatic moments but as a whole
never felt like it took itself too
seriously not to the point where it
mocked its original Source material and
its concept like most modern superhero
movies conflate that stylistic technique
with but in a way it embrace the
inherent silliness and allowed itself to
have fun and be campy at times but this
one almost completely buoys itself if
any sort of owning it you do get some
crazy visuals which I greatly appreciate
but they stand out like a sore thumb
when it comes to the rest which is so
dark and gritty it's almost dull which
is kind of ironic and then there's the
fact that Johnny's personality has been
pretty effectively Stripped Away here
you could almost argue it's because of
the stress of being a The Ghost Writer
but even then the tortured Soul stuff
barely comes across the directors lean
into more of his cageisms that he's
Infamous for which they understandably
were excited about the star of our movie
is
Nicolas Cage
when
but it's not only wildly and consistent
from his character it also strips him
with being one he's more of an element
in the plot than the main focus because
we have to spend so much time worrying
about this dumb Antichrist John Connor
kid who has the map to dry land tattooed
on his back in the immunity to the
mushrooms but this kid and Johnny don't
bond nearly enough to care about him
like those other characters though it's
not food
lack of struggling to even try
now nothing is really the central Focus
actually there's so many characters and
so many things going on in this movie
and all of it feels like an afterthought
somehow like it's all just randomly
plugged in script elements to
approximate the structure of a movie and
move us from the action scene to action
scene
I've watched this movie like six times
and I sometimes forget that Idris Elba
in the [__] Highlander are in it he's
also right Jinx what are you Anna what
are you a frozen fan touche
is shorter than the original and the
pacing is very fast not just because of
the many sped up shots throughout but
it's like Johnny we gotta go here and I
need you to do this and then we gotta go
here and then I need you to do this and
we gotta go here and I need you just
like dick I mean do this what do you
mean by that off the back if I'm feeling
like more of an element than a character
Johnny doesn't really have any stake in
this whole situation outside of The
Exorcism of zarathos which surprisingly
isn't mentioned in the original with
that being his origin and all the card
is slayed being his mentor stuff him
getting so attached to Danny feels weird
because he doesn't really have any
significance to him in the plot outside
of Monroe needing the rider to track him
in order to save him plus in the
exorcism process Johnny lets out that
suppressed Guild of his actions with his
father that guided him in the last movie
was wanting to do good in order to make
up for it another deal for me
I couldn't let him go
it was selfish
which is good and all if his character
wasn't so wildly inconsistent from the
first up to the point in the exorcism
the behind the scenes content from this
movie it's slap Dash and Breakneck
nature started to make a lot more sense
not just with the editing but how
quickly the story seems to want to go by
an interesting piece of information came
up when it came to the screenwriting
process this is the first movie that the
duo directed that they didn't write that
credit goes to Scott M gimple Seth
Hoffman and David S goyer a goyer
project with trumpet production where
have I heard that before uh don't worry
it's not to that extent this script was
apparently done even before the original
Ghost Rider movie the directors
described it as a hard R Fusion of Lord
of the Rings The Da Vinci Code The
Grudge meets Mad Max which all sounds
terrible to me but the studio called for
rewrites to condense the ideas and
elements of the original script to make
it more focused and restrain themselves
on the budget this digging up and
revising of the older script caused the
production process to be super rushed
the directors were out of their element
here with the studio used to doing
things a certain way and the duo doing
things uh
a totally different unconventional way
there's just moments where you can see
them blatantly being sick of this [__]
they were having to deal with while
working on this thing it was it was a
rush pre-pro schedule it's so rushed
that we we you know we ended up shooting
a Romania but we found out we were
supposed to be shooting in Hungary
a major part of their approach was
trying to make this a globetrotting
adventure and shooting on location that
was a hassle of miscommunication when it
comes to fees and permit limitations or
the major budget difference between the
first film and this or even the gear not
being able to get to them when they
needed it kind of sucks seeing it in
retrospect like there's even more that
went wrong than that it's just like a
lot actually do you want to cover all
that who me yeah I mean all that deep
dive stuff seems more your speed Mr 58
minute video That's supposed to come out
in January man shut the [__] up uh yes
sir like not now you know it's kind of
inconvenient to my time but like you
know inevitably that means go subscribe
and stay tuned as he would put it why
are you saying it as if you have an
automatic 45 caliber rifle pointed
directly into the tight hole of your
rectum I would not in my life know what
you're referring to sir
as a man whose life is Gorilla let alone
my style and short films made so far
movie making is a very difficult task
that needs considerable time and
preparation to be done efficiently and
it sucks to see yet another Soul taken
away from a victim of the studio mandate
it's a shame that this series of films
is characterized by being wildly
inconsistent then fizzling Into
Obscurity
the Marvel Knights line of films could
have been a nice adult oriented
alternative to the more summer
blockbuster MCU fair but the world
wasn't quite ready for R-rated
superheroes and the only two movies that
came out of that label were this and
Punisher war zone which we talked about
last month and I guess the most of
comics if you really want to get
technical with adopting most of its
characters on screen now Marvel Studios
is put in a weird situation where they
have to continue their stories in a way
that were originally presented case in
point them continuing the Deadpool
series of movies whether you're not you
like those movies I do they're a
successful mainstream example of
explicit content made in the superhero
movie climate and presumably while
Disney doesn't want to seem to fully
commit to carrying over that element
when it comes to other franchises the
same form of expression they wouldn't be
dumb enough to stop milking that cow
sucking from its utter and Golfing down
all the flowing juices that come with it
why are my pants getting so down the
line we potentially have room for them
to venture out into different avenues
for riskier characters that can't really
even border that family-friendly Mark
but until then Ryan I'll see you in your
default settings acting range there
future of Ghost Rider in cinema as murky
at the moment without showing his human
form we know Johnny Blaze's Ghostwriter
appears in Agents of Shield to pass the
skull torch to Robbie Reyes which was
cool as [__] but they stopped using him
in that show because you could see the
budget burning in his head and every
scene he was in there's talk of a
rumored Mephisto special on Disney plus
soon but I fear it's been so long that
he's become more of a Spider-Man villain
and they may not even use Ghost Rider
for that we shall see either way MCU
Ghost Rider most likely won't be
Nicholas Cage I don't need to be in the
MCU I'm Nick Cage
foreign
you know that that self-confidence is
good I scoff at the base responses to
this clip I'm not really on that train I
think he's more based for taking his
stage name from Luke Cage from Marvel
Comics to naming his kid after Superman
but it is what it is you know in the end
Ghost Rider is a strange duology that
feels like the trilogy That Never Was
it's
killed for one of these things to
sputter out at just two usually your
first movie bombs or you go the distance
and get that trilogy and everyone hates
the third one Amazing Spider-Man with
special circumstances because that
movie's success was going to make or
break the whole Cinematic Universe it
was in but its budget was grossly
inflated truly the Black Adam of its
time Ghost Rider on the other hand
appeared in the transition stages of
superhero movies and could have helped
to Usher us into the CBM Renaissance no
matter how much this thing needed it
thank god well I guess with this though
that it wasn't delayed in the next year
because it's probably not hard to
imagine the blowback The Duel would have
experienced having their movie come out
the same year as The Avengers aka the
film that every Blockbuster franchise
going onward wish to have in this
catalog but didn't have the backbone
as a foundation to live off of arguably
including the same Studio came from it
would probably suck granny [__]
slabby Flapjacks if I'm gonna be honest
for them to have to go through that
spirit of Vengeance felt like something
that was too old hat by going for a dark
grounded and realistic approach to
something that should be balls to the
wall fun all the way through
it reminds me of the early 2000
superhero movies and all the bad ways
instead of the good ways of its
predecessor showing restraint in the
worst places
everything with the writer himself goes
insanely hard and is so cool and
exciting but nothing else in the movie
strives for that Ghost Rider is the most
magical and crazy and exciting thing in
his own movie and he's surrounded by
gray dull lifeless grounded takes on his
Mythos he should have been fighting
seven foot tall Red Demon Mephisto were
going to hell himself
a boring and uncreative story can't be
saved by Fun directing and Whippy
editing the movie is like dry flavorless
meat getting doused barbecue sauce it's
nice to have that initial kick but you
know under the spice you're just eating
cardboard so while Thor was showing
Asgard gnaw's glory and Iron Man was
battling big bad villains with powers
that rival his own and Captain America
was chasing Cosmic cubes all in like the
span of a year from this movie's release
this ends up feeling quaint and
unexciting it's just Johnny Blaze
without his powers for much of the run
time hanging out in the desert it's not
a small scale or character-driven story
it has apocalyptic connotations in one
of Marvel's biggest and most powerful
villains but it doesn't do anything with
either of those it's a road trip movie
with barely any road trip it's an end of
the world movie with no end of the world
and it's a Ghostwriter movie that barely
cares about Ghost Rider himself when
he's not on fire
the first movie did it right that's a
simple and small scale story in the
right way Johnny's the big focus and we
like him and he goes through a lot of
changes in that movie The Plot is simple
but effective he's just rounding up a
handful of dissidents from hell and
black heart wants a McGuffin that'll let
him Dethrone Mephisto they know Daniel
Mephisto is the main antagonist and have
him be a punk [__] that does nothing
the first movie inspired a lot of
confidence that flamehead could stand
shoulder to shoulder with some of the
biggest superheroes from Marvel
but instead this sequel is so boneless
that they got left behind oh I see what
you did I always get mad at YouTube for
not putting my videos in the
subscription box because people will
comment finally Xavier uploads again
after all these years not knowing three
other videos came out within the last
month already so maybe that stupid Bell
icon thing will help you remember I
exist if you want other ways to support
the channel you can always go hit up
that patreon for early videos and
exclusive stuff because it's just a
dollar I'm not kidding it's only one
dollar Isn't that cool if everyone who
watched this video donated one dollar a
month I'd be able to afford a house for
myself so that would be that would be
really cool you can also check out our
merch on T public or just buy some of my
random stuff on eBay I have a pretty
substantial collection of old toys that
are still in the box in perfect
condition so go take a look in case you
find something you like and lastly since
this is a YouTube video and you probably
play fortnite drop my Creator quote
Xavier GM next time you buy a silly
dancer cool character skin really helps
me out
see you next time
[Music]
foreign